malgré sa position de leader chaque
année tf1 perd du terrain en audience
par rapport à ses concurrentes la chaîne
fait 18 8% de part de marché sur l'année
soit une baisse de 0,4 pour cent sur un
an
la faute en partie à ces après midi qui
se font littéralement mettre ko par ceux
de france 2 on essaie de répondre à
votre attente sophie davant avec à faire
conclut faustine bollaert avec ça
commence aujourd'hui
ou encore daphné bürki et je t'aime et
cetera met à mal les programmes de tf1
ce sont des symboles très fort qu'est ce
qui se passe il faut dire qu'avant 17h
et les plus belles marié de karine ferri
tf1 ne diffuse que des téléfilms qui ont
bien du mal à fidéliser les
téléspectateurs et faire face aux
animatrices tard de france télé persia
tôt ce port est le fils aîné comme le
pari de france 2 de faire incarner ces
après midis et donc 100% gagnant reste à
savoir si tf1 au tapis pour l'instant va
décidé de riposter et de se relever
après ce ko technique on est dur là les
chiens affaire à suivre
[Applaudissements]
on a fait surtout dans les numéros
d'hier le deuxième numéro d'affaires
conclues a fait le double de tech 1 là
c'est quand même assez significatif et
surtout tf1 réalisé au mois de janvier
une audience moyenne
historiquement bas notamment à cause de
ces après midi très fort cher il faut
rappeler que février et janvier sont les
deux plus gros mois en terme d'audience
que tout le monde est dans la télévision
paradoxalement c'est là où il ya le
moins de plus parce qu'ils ont tous des
bons ses fourneaux elle un peu après
nicolas pernikoff qu'est ce que ça vous
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire aspect est
ce que ça m'inspire de chercher
simplement que la mission de service
public c'est de mettre en avant du
contenu et pas forcément et chercher
l'audience immédiate
la chance du service public c'est
qu'elle elle temps on a parlé souvent
ici le plus belle la vie qui avait signé
trois cent soixante cinq épisodes à vous
souvenez il y avait un contrat d'un an
dont il n'avait pas d'autre choix que de
laisser plus belle la vie au quotidien
avec l'admr géant sera pas plus que
qatar un accident industriel
pareil je sais pas si vous rappelez
début de l'après midi de france 2 mais
kevin doit s'en souvenir
tout le monde l'a critiqué tout le monde
a dit mais c'est n'importe quoi pourquoi
mettre des émissions après midi les plus
gros succès à l'époque il n'y avait que
cinq six chaînes de télévision s'étaient
toutes ces émissions d'accompagnement
avec dechavanne de mémoire marck b soul
c'est encore mieux l'après midi vous
sauver c'est ses émissions
accompagnement le matin il y avait matin
bonheur avec thierry beccaro lit des
mines il ya des téléspectateurs qui ont
besoin de regarder des émissions
d'accompagnement l'après midi servez
vous n'êtes pas de la bonne génération 6
mai il ya un public à la fois juste si
je vous suis ça veut dire que le fait de
laisser les émissions s'installer quoi
bien sûr qu'il a rimé sa fille regarde
ce qui va se passer sur tf1 tf1
aujourd'hui est un téléfilm quasiment de
14 heures à 17 heures ils vont finir par
remettre du jeu tout doucement on va
remettre des émissions de fruits et du
jeu de plus en plus on le voit bien il
ya de plus en plus de recherches de jeux
sur toutes les chaînes
donc je pense qu un mort-né tf1 va
reconstruire son après-midi le fond de
l'air est ce que c'est un choix tf1 en
gros de désengager ses investissements
sur l'année de l'après midi qui n'est
pas un enjeu économique de ouf et se
construit sur les prime times alors que
france 2 rame un peu plus élevé un effet
locomotive c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné quand vous avez le public qui
arrive sur france 2 en début d'après
midi que vous arrivez à le fidéliser il
reste après sûr n'oubliez pas les
paroles qui est de plus en plus haut je
crois que n'oubliez pas les paroles
n'est pas loin de 20 % d'audience
aujourd'hui un peu baissé avec la
les années sert elle à la sortie
effectivement de la gagnante mais c'est
quand même des scores incroyables plus
de 4 millions de téléspectateurs sur
france 2 ce sont les scores qui n'ont
pas été atteints depuis quasiment 15 ans
vous pensez vraiment que les gens sont
assez grégaire pour pas employer un
terme un peu ça les gars aient accès des
boutons aux et qui se suivent lebron
pour magali non voici donc les gens
parce qu'ils sont sur france 2 à 14 - ac
jusqu'à 23h quelques les gens changent
pas de chaîne honnêtement c'est un
avenant il ya un effet locomotive
vraiment on le sait bien on sait bien
qu'il ya les leading c'est à dire que
quand vous avez une émission que vous
donne un petit peu avant par exemple
vous vous avez une émission qu'avant
vous avez un peu de publicité
après vous reprenez l'audience après la
pub avant s'est massée dès lors commencé
matthieu delormeau une obligation aussi
de diffusion de quotas de fiction
française parce que comme il diffuse
énormément de fiction américaine le soir
oui on impose aussi de balancer des
fictions vous savez que l'effet des
programmes courts puisque madriers
programme court sur toutes les chaînes
que tout le monde connaît que ce soit
sur m6 ou tf1 c'est fait pour ça c'est à
dire que à un moment donné tout le monde
partait à cause de la pub
maintenant on essaie de reffye d'élise
et en ayant des points avec des scores
avec des scores énorme incroyable mer et
la crds incroyable